check oh hell no like every 20 I said I
would like like you know when we talked
about this before we like listen to a
podcast and we don't really remember
what we said like like we laugh in the
same parts when we're listening to it
it's like oh [ __ ] me in the podcast
laughs and then you're my mind was it
the same joke and then me in the podcast
will make the joke haha that you forgot
you may like oh [ __ ] where it's like an
alternate ran because they're doing a
podcast it is like a simulation here you
know where you're like like viewing your
past self and don't realize you do that
guy it's like when you make what was
that by have a hard time listening to
myself me too well you know what like I
wouldn't listen it's hard for me to
listen to like a stand-up thing but the
podcast because yeah we don't remember
like I forget so much like I'll just
sometimes I'll just be like oh you know
listen to some of that gay cuz I
remember laughing hey gang cloud goes in
waves oh yeah where it's just like Oh
something that really funny happened I
want to listen have someone listen to it
or or we hear clips from like three
years ago yeah I'm gonna post something
or whatever ok they want yeah really
have this one
[Music]
Oh Flemish well fine have another video
today I've got some a loop hello not
sure sound effects pack everybody has
their little everybody on youtube like
they have to put their like fake
production company load oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh this is M so funny by
really no that's the same guy yeah i was
just saying before we start the podcast
last time I saw you Shane was in Central
Oregon work near where I grew up yeah
she's pretty cool and there was like a
couple a couple people a couple bones
own people showed up that who are fans
of Shannon fans of the podcast and I
brought my friend I won't name his name
but he's now a vice principal of a
school in that area and he went says
Shane's drug show how about oh and he
was like cool principal he's like I'm
like yeah and he was like he's like it
makes me want to like try you know I was
like that's you know he's very open
minded he he's not a maze like a hunter
he's like kind of conservative but not
really yeah but yeah I was like that's
cool like I wish like the staff of my
middle school growing up was as
open-minded as it is now because he was
like I you know might suck if I bump
into like a parent or something I her on
mushrooms or something yeah well right
when we walked in there was a lady by
the front door and he was like oh hey
and they started talking and I was like
oh no I was like whos that hes like
that's the vice principal of one of the
high schools i know it's like you know
even someone else was there I saw
haven't seen your drug show Shane I wish
I tried to in New Orleans but it was too
crowded he could use do it for us yeah
yeah I mean that would be great because
Randy and I had a long day a part-time
job at stuff you want like extended
version yeah how long is that welcomes
in about two and a half hour I don't
know just feel like an hour oh yeah well
shout stop really loud when we tighten
up I don't know if I can tighten it up
that much I can I guess I
can you give me like an hour 20 damn
dude oh you're interested prepare to
have your mind expanded by the mind of
Sheamus throwing out the truth bomb
expanding your reality now welcome to
the stage Shane ma I actually just did
some weird it was someone reached out to
me they'd seen me do the show in Oregon
and then they were like I am an
assistant or intern or something for
some sort of radio show that's
such-and-such like herbal healing radio
or something like that and and I just
like it as like okay you know whatever
and then and then next thing I know it's
just like okay here's a questionnaire of
a hundred things you have to fill out
ahead of time to like prep for like if
you're doing morning radio like lead-in
for jokes or boat it's just like what do
you want to talk its own name ten things
that you want to talk about and like
write out the question so I finally and
I like put it off and put it off into I
don't like I'll sit down and write she
spent two hours yeah we're riding out
this thing for like a 30 minute you know
like that I don't know what this thing
is yeah I'm going to listen to so
finally this this woman I I get a call
and and it's just like this really
really old like hippie lady yeah like
her tea something like 30 75 80 yes you
start tonight with a like a rock that
like mineral crystals ya got a crystal
in her [ __ ] yeah Crusoe scopus yeah hey
coming up next year she yes they say and
I starts doing like they were like what
do you want on the website or whatever
and so I just copy and pasted my dumb
bio from my website or whatever i'm sure
we get on and and so she's like from
Wisconsin he caught his break in 2007
like reefer and I was like oh no and
then she starts like Conan like oh and
she's like I don't know who any of these
people are I haven't I haven't had a TV
since uh since JFK was assassinated it
was like you got rid of your TV like
exactly when Jenny was fascinated like I
don't see any time now and and I was
like okay I was like you could just you
don't have to say all that like you
gives us and I just like kind of making
a joke of it uh-huh and she's talking
about you know like she's like this very
serious person and so I was just like
having you know trying to have like
she'd asked me about some I'd try to
like give her like an answer about yes
here's the therapeutic benefits of
psychedelic sure what I like to yeah
that's what you wanted done like 15
minutes and she's like I thought you're
gonna be funny haha she's like you know
niche she goes well i have to tell you
saying your your stand-up comedian and i
heard you're going to be funny i'm just
gonna have to ask you to tell me a joke
have I easily I can tell you good job
like you're gonna just pump the brakes
right now I'm in casual genuine
conversation that we're having for me to
tell you a little skit and she's like
yep yeah i think really bye and then I
was like oh like I almost hung up but
yes I get it I was like I didn't know if
my PR person line this I didn't know
until afterwards when I looked back at
it was just like I should have just hung
up yeah yeah I didn't want like my PR
person yeah and so I was just saying
like I had old crystal [ __ ] lady really
see if you got my other clients on the
cups all-purpose podcast and then it's
so like I told a joke ice moved it over
with you need to have a conversation
well she asked about like breaking my
feet or whatever and I told some like
whatever I could remember from my album
about breaking my feet and then
and then and she didn't laugh at all and
then I tried to like get back into
having a gender and I was like saying
funny thing you know like well I'd
either been a while yeah she has her
sense of humor hasn't has been developed
since then she's like you're gonna do
this all right all right all right guy
you know and then at the end again like
she's like okay well we gotta wrap up
here and she goes well you know you
weren't as funny as I pleasure coming to
me that's what I crotchety old you I
mean like I guess certain lady's age
differently she facebook is all just
like love circles and stuff like that
and everyone's like holding hands and
like feeling universal love and then and
then she's just like this pecker were
like say something funny damn dude hey
yeah you have stay away from those
pretty woman loved in the wild that's
always a way to like the the most
complicated annoying you know where it's
like okay I'm doing someone a favor and
they're asking me all this [ __ ] okay
I'll do it I'll do it in and it just
winds up it's like you're an [ __ ] day
I was like those be funny to like the
questionnaire that they gave you like if
you lived your life like a morning radio
where you had somebody go ahead before
you go into like a social gathering and
they give everybody yeah write down some
leading questions for Randy before he
gets in here and then like Randy walks
in with cards so oh um so I hear that I
you're ready I hear you're writing on a
new thing yeah I can tell me about that
oh I'm glad you asked me that in real
life and then as you're talking i'm
giving you the like wrap it up like okay
we're gonna have to stop for breaking it
in a second here we're going to i had a
thing recently i was in san francisco i
had two experiences on the radio in san
francisco last month where one guy just
went to my Wikipedia page we've got all
these questions from there but my
Wikipedia page like anybody can edit it
so all of our crazy [ __ ] bones Oh
people there's just all this dumb untung
[ __ ]
there and the guys like so you toured
with my Jeff Dunham what was that like
hahaha I didn't I never met the guy okay
I actually oh yeah from two thousand six
to two thousand eight Walsh toured
extensively as the opening act for Jeff
Dunham it says and uh and then it said I
want a hundred thousand dollars in a
comedy contest and I feel like it's
kinda I won ten thousand dollars like
years ago I was like oh yeah I was ten
thousand and it was uh daughters there
was another uh oh and then yeah that me
and Randy are twins with different
birthdays hahahahaha and every question
he asked me I'm like now I was like yeah
you know Wikipedia is not a good source
so like that that was like kind of fun
because I get made it more fun than if
he was just like look at my bio like oh
so you got your starter often tell ya so
that like made it kind of interesting
and fun for me and then there was
another guy the the next radio show
where he said he's like so do you have
any you know what do you talk about in
your act or whatever you talk about yeah
all because I think I was like sorry I
like I what's your assessment humor like
what kind of jokes do you think asked me
if I got political or I don't know I
think cuz i was like talking about like
911 or somewhere i was like ours an
inside job or whatever he's like you
really believe that i was like well yeah
I mean I think it's pretty rational but
not everybody seems to agree yeah and
he's like what do you think what are you
talking about like what's and I was like
I mean you know it's pretty casual i
just kind of like he's like what's you
know what's like a bit that like what's
your favorite joke and I was like well I
mean there is this thing that I really
like doing but it's very new and like I
don't want people to like I don't know I
kind of want to save it for people who
come to the show he's like I just do and
I was like well I mean you know I talked
about like well my grand moms in the
hospital and they're like oh no I go no
no it's great she's having a baby and
they were like what wait hold on for
real and I'm having a baby so I'm gonna
have a baby uncle and they're like wait
is this hold on i'm like we know it's
not my grandmom's not like you are first
like hey do a joke knock knock what
what's up like that yeah what is it
someone get up and yeah what do we do i
also like when after shows when people
like what people think is real and what
is made up for my act i'll be like so
did you really break your feet if I I
just know I just made up that our story
but then they'll be like so what was it
like to time travel and have a sex
change and then tuck yourself how are
you yours your [ __ ] meter is off I
can oh yeah I can always tell when
someone read my Wikipedia page because
when someone goes to interview me
they'll always because whoever wrote my
Wikipedia page just like found a bunch
of newspaper articles and you know like
the newspaper articles always have to
like make some hero story up like when I
caught a few breaks early on and I was
like this Boston guy done well and then
like read a page long thing about like
in any triumphed over the adversity of
bit yeah you know trying to spice up
yeah straight white dude that yeah I got
a problem and and and so so I always
know because they're like so uh you had
like a lot of like anxiety homme before
like starting I you read that on
Wikipedia yeah yeah yeah like I always
bail right away there was actually that
and the name of the podcast escapes me
but I told you about it it was like when
you were going to be in philly it was a
guy in New Jersey who does yeah yeah and
that was one I felt almost back because
that's the thing like you do so many
weird shitty things that you're like
this is pointless and why am I here and
not like there was a lot of press in
Philadelphian like and I was being kind
of shitty to the girl who was taking me
around because the last thing we had to
do she was this podcast in New Jersey
and she's like that's like 20 minutes
away and I'm like well it's a podcast I
looked at their twitter I have like ten
times the amount of Twitter followers
it's not going to air before the show I
don't know why I'm doing this like I
want to go back to my hotel and she's
like well I mean it's I'm like a fine
I'm sorry you know I'm just
kind of like annoyed that hired driving
the new jersey to do a podcast and it
was like the BET like this guy I would
have felt so bad why wouldn't have known
but like if like because I almost was
going to put my foot down and be like no
just go back to the hotel i'm not doing
this and it would have been so shitty
because this guy did hours of research
like he was the most like well
researched like interview I've ever
where I was like holy [ __ ] I forgot
about that I'm like how did where did
you even find that and he was a great
guy of howling two of those ever I know
yeah that's I think that's the only one
that was like a legitimate like and he
wasn't a freak too cuz it's hard to
balance like there could be a guy who
knows a lot about you but he's like so
ah yeah so you still with that girl he
is free I have to figure out that the
name of that podcast cuz it's good you
should listen to it oh there's some guy
in Atlanta that did one with more I
think you know everything about me and
my career like do you do this every time
you have you I'll try to figure this one
out it was a you want to try to
replicate the singing of this oh hell no
sound drop me you want to hear it again
yeah I'm not sure I have it oh pretty
good you would give it a shot Raymond
yeah here oh hell no I'm gonna try it oh
[Laughter]
hell no
oh I keep messing up at the very edge
again no more time wow you're getting me
know like right but you're not blowing
it right out fabulous archiving the
laughs the last part goes it does like a
wah but yeah the last parts tricky so I
paused because a lot the time before
that I ran it all together too much
tricky I mean I'm not gonna try it out
tricky try to guess we should can we
just all do it at the exact same time
okay we'll listen to it okay and then do
it in unison good yeah oh it's pretty
yes it sounded beautiful doing also one
in speaker for that I know he's saying
Henry Phillips is on the podcast a
couple weeks ago and and we went down
the we did this yeah yeah it hasn't been
very long completed this is good we
didn't call anyone though no we could
call someone that I have to tell us
which one has the better one ok ok I'm
would be a good place to judge our sing
right now who wanna [ __ ] up what's like
a place where you'd expect there to be
like a lot of uh I mean a lot of record
spinning around record store yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean that seems like they
listen to a lot of music yeah there's
some of them are probably she not a liar
to be singers know like a lot of
guitarists work at a guitar store before
they get famous probably i worked at a
mic stand place before I oh really yeah
how you look at your microphone eek yeah
some microphones and and small stages Oh
oh you can't spit you got stopped
practicing like your god are you gonna
I'm just a pretty good singer I actually
tweeted to Josh Groban today and told
him I'm a better singer than he accepted
it he really yeah he responded he
responded me to me before yeah where I
told him that I'm a better singer than
him and he was like yeah I know you're
not or whatever I mean he by all
accounts he's a like a good guy like
another good Center no no oh I know I'm
not saying he's not a good singer I'm
just saying I'm just as good see then
that would make me think that maybe he's
not that good of a singer if you're just
so then you're saying that I'm not that
cab solutely buckaroo are you serious
yeah right in your face I'm telling you
it the last podcast we did remember ice
I was singing at the beginning and doing
all the octave yeah yeah I'd say you're
as good as me maybe maybe not even uh oh
this is I've never seen this side I ran
oh well like Randy's always respected
I've been ours is the first time I've
ever seen either one of you call one
another a buckaroo yeah I'm a little
uncomfortable with a little lover's
bridge I was like he's kind of I think
it and here and I'm not being stop me if
I'm out of line okay but I feel like up
at not keep go I feel like Randy's I got
my oh he's a little doing a little tired
of living in my shadow yeah whoa like
yesterday I'm like I'm not saying really
a bad singer oh but I'm just saying that
it's like it's time to like he feels
like it's time to challenge me okay
we're like like I don't know it was like
Roman times don't like guys who train
guys how to fight with sword then that
guy tries to kill him with the sword
yeah yeah usually it's like a sing-off
after that like when the sword fight
doesn't work well let's I'll back up and
I won't listen I at least don't think
here as good as josh groban is that like
the first time I'm hearing you say this
Oh used to agree with me we can go back
and listen to the podcast yeah I mean I
think it's okay for each of you to have
your own opinion and
feeling but and and maybe you can
communicate them in a way that isn't
hurtful to the other wanting in more
styles than josh groban but I can sing
okay I'll do that all hell no in Josh
Groban style oh but I can also do okay
so okay here's prepared to react arrest
buckaroo so I can do it in that style oh
hell no i don't like right how much for
not trying much right contra josh groban
couldn't replicate that okay but i can
do it the way josh groban would do it
sure well no look again yeah well I mean
I have my eyes closed I was trying to
pre I extra visualize you know maybe
want to get josh groban's number and you
have a sing-off one day we will baby so
what is this a record store a record
exchange I think it's movies and okay
thank you for calling Geo records on
sahara this is christian not gonna help
ya hey christian i this is brennan i'm
here with Randy and Shane and we were
just arguing about who's a better singer
I was what could you just listen to this
for one second this is uh that's that's
none of us but I can that's what we're
trying to replicate that's what we're
trying to replicate me you have to judge
I'll go first so number one alright so
here's number we get my let me get my
judges cap on real quick all right let's
do this all right so you want to hear
the original recording again real quick
it's just one more time yep okay yep
just this now that I'm prepared yeah
let's go now here at number one this is
me this is brennan oh no
ah all right all right you just totally
got a bath oh sorry not bad yeah I'm
insolent okay now this one is a shame
all right oh I like that one I like that
one and now we're Andy all right now
Randy oh hello alright imma go Andy man
hey you guys have any other stuff maybe
we need executive me Michael remind me
he's about four more job thank you so
much my friend Brendan think there's a
better singer than Josh Groban arguing
so are you familiar with Josh Groban I'm
not too familiar with his music at all
no all right we'll check this out tell
me if you think that Josh Grove this I'm
going to sing something just a line in
the Josh Groban style and tell me if you
think it's just as good if not better
than Josh Groban all right
[Music]
I
yeah that's that was the whole no it's a
whole he's still thinking about it hello
did you like that sir and that was that
was killer man see oh thanks are you are
you an aspiring musician or anything no
no no I'm not but I would definitely say
that was better than Josh Groban thank
you oh dang ding ding ding you want to
try to sing the hell no song you don't
have to but you know what let me hear
let me hear contestant number 2 again oh
okay here long I'll play the original
one again just to refresh your memory
all right go for it oh alright here
comes a shame this is number 20 Karen uh
I'll just I'll do 12 just not for me Oh
still number three I feel like uh well
oh I'm still leaning towards 30 all the
truth hurts sometimes so we appreciate
your honesty I feel so good thank you so
much it sounds like there's some chicks
in there are there some chick shopping
in there there's always chicks shopping
in here man what what what's the name of
the place again Ziggy record can you put
one of the girls on the phone I am
totally not going to put a customer on
the phone I don't blame you but that's
disappointing yeah um just out of
curiosity how much have you guys been
drinking or smoking tonight i'm
completely sober yet he said yeah what
one of us has been drinking that's
that's a very reasonable question and
I'm
yeah I just said I had two scoops of
chocolate ice cream and I'm i'm a 36
years old and sober yeah and tonight not
not 36 years sober I'm a 36 year old who
is sober tonight yeah and calling you to
see who is a better singer mandurah
handy is we're all in our 30 overall you
guys sell any rock and roll like
t-shirts and stuff there yeah yeah we've
got some teachers and stuff do you have
any t-shirts that looks like a car ran
them over like that tire tracks going
across the chest no nothing that nothing
that classic look into one of those
shoot what's your number one selling
records these days number one sewn
record um-hmm it usually changes man
right now right now if we're selling if
we're saying just records I would say
hmm Pink Floyd now Pink Floyd kind of
slowed down a little bit once we Roger
Ottomans at Arnhem oh you know what I
bet prince and David Bowie your time
strongly lately actually no man it's
always like the new artist then they
always smell strongly for like a month
and then nobody buys their records ever
again you guys it's always how it goes
man and then you know there's no one
there's the occasional person that will
come in and pick up like you know one
person will buy all of Prince records or
one person will come in through by all
of Bowie's records or you know one
person will come through and buy all of
the doors but no one really like picks
up the same you know does it I don't see
the same record over and over and over
coming up you know it's always it's
always an even spread especially with
records you know everyone has their own
taste but CDs man CDs
Shh let's definitely man real everyone's
always by Led Zeppelin Led Zeppelin CDs
yeah we still use the CD player no yeah
that's what makes them okay what about
DVD their tops on DVDs oh man dr.
strange just came out tonight so
everyone's picking that up well tell
them everybody who's buying a doctor
strange DVD tell them they [ __ ] up
because they should have seen it in imax
3d yeah have you ever done dmae Doctor
Strange is a lot like bmt yeah no no I
have it we should all do it sometime
yeah we should all get together and
smoke some dmt yeah shane has a whole
show about it yeah I do it's true right
on man yeah uh what's your name again my
name is Christian oh that's pretty good
yeah all right Christian why are you on
vegas i am yes are you doing any shows
in Vegas anytime soon she went through
vegas no i am a regular old record store
worker no I'd of all yeah I was kind of
man vegas i was just in vegas a is this
fun man but I have some other cousin
asked me questions you guys have
anything else I can help you out with no
I could talk about a little more scores
anything else we're doing but one of
those hot chicks on the phone ma'am look
at my mad hey you just asked if there
were chicks in the store you didn't ask
for any hot sugar I can't help you with
that I mean anything I'll propose to
them right on the phone oh yeah put us
over the the speaker in the store will
propose to the girls in unison okie Dok
well we love you Christian enough girls
in here to all say yes oh damn well
thanks Christian we love you man Thanks
no worries i look at you guys love you
that day to take it easy to really rest
you guys night and all that good jazz
yeah well Simon love you
I take it easy fellas money why we got
to save that number yeah that's a good
nitrogen emigrate Christian was the best
I mean that's like that was really very
patient he was like you know that's the
way I feel most people should behave
when they get a call for ya like instead
of cuz you go one of two directions like
you answer the phone I say listen I'm
gonna play a clip we're all going to
sing it for you tell us who's best you
go listen I'm really busy this is our do
you have a question concerning dvds or
records yeah yeah well that's really you
should be working in a record store what
yeah I'm like a job that doesn't if you
want just like a real casual yeah work
where you can where you lay on the phone
yeah you can take but a lot of people
have jobs like that and they're like
listen our policy is that we don't judge
singing well we have wedding dresses to
sell happy I mean that was a Christian
was great not as good as it could have
gotten yes that's it so um thanks for
listening everybody it's another episode
of the bone zone starring brendan walsh
guest host Randy litke and secondary
guest post no we got we got lots of time
left we got lots of I was just saving
christians phone number in my song it
was a cool guy he was honest about not
being busy you know he could he could he
could handle the call he wasn't that
busy and then when it finally was like a
little bit too much and maybe he needed
to do some stuff at her and he was chill
I mean it doesn't make for a good
calmness and so we kind of like to drive
people crazy but it was it was a fun
outcome who would have thought we would
have called this week he would have he
would have crowned me the king better
than Brendan who he I gotta say I did
choke a little bit about other said
brendan is better than Josh grow
and I'm better than Brendan so whoa I
know got a cool i'm kind of the new king
of vocal yep yes you sang that one thing
maybe a little bit better and also you
know this goes into so we already had a
record store settle this I feel like I
mean also you have we good we're good
before someone else no because I already
got to keep God I had a feeling we
should call a record store play multiple
old phone calls and then have them judge
which was the better phone call I think
we should do this two more time why men
have them judge which person responded
to it I think people oh yes five hours
on I think people generally vote for the
last they like if you're if you say okay
which one you like one two or three this
last one they heard they're like oh 3
because that's like the freshest in
their mind but it's really bad fundable
oh look at these anything not to
distract that I'm looking at the reviews
the place we just called friendly staff
no one of them to des for the customer
service I have had mostly great customer
service go and then here's why 0 degree
this one's this place had a lot of good
vinyl very reasonably priced the staff
were helpful and incredibly nice
suspiciously almost too nice pretty
crazy that's uh maybe it's an affront or
something that's pretty crazy it holds
up it holds up man suspiciously too nice
yeah it was yeah as I was a little
uncomfortable why ya think I was
obsessed with us damn Chris rude sorry
this is supposed to be the Indiana Jones
teams like somebody put that if I was
trying to find our theme song and I
podcast son to karate at Marcia Clark
one
jurassic park has a rocket as a cart is
drastic drastic graduate are welcome to
Jurassic Park we have been so lost
dinosaur in tragic tragic tragic tragic
heart Emily Rose the Indiana Jones right
at Disneyland and on our way out that's
why i was playing over sing address my
way out I was like what the [ __ ] the
Jurassic drastic just to walk down
memory lane listen folks for your new
listener what you're not we were hanging
on to like 11 people now our numbers are
everything we're increasing every week
go back listen to some classic bone
zones there's some good stuff in there I
get a lot of people come out I get a lot
of bones owner you really yeah a couple
people each show yeah yeah very here
there's always a couple yeah do they
like to reminisce about his own ability
we had a pretty good like one of the
first times maybe they'll sound like
I've not it's not like I'm on that often
so yeah have to have people coming out
regularly that had heard me that means
their regular listeners yeah yeah yeah
that's pretty good we had a pretty epic
red lobster call like the first time you
were on yeah or one of the first times
we're calling what the hell i forget
what the what the what the idea was oh
we ready to get a delivery yeah yeah
lobsters delivered I'm Red Lobster and
we're they deliver we were like behaving
like we were a live show so we're I
forget what it was can't remember either
but yeah we just kept being like okay
and then you can just deliver it and
they like no we don't like they kept
having a crack that's fine well you
could just deliver it and then that
would be great
[Laughter]
um do you guys want to call us i texted
Brennan because I thought I saw the sign
oh yeah and I thought it would be fun
would you trade 15 hours a week or a
hundred thousand dollars yeah hundred
thousand dollars a week and I can't well
let's clarify this is 15 hours if it
because I saw it like this is like this
shitty tagboard like a sign that you'd
see for like a rummage sale this way
like a magic marker as like want to make
a hundred thousand dollars yeah a
hundred thousand dollars out of a better
sorry 50 yeah what'd he do to me that I
where can I fix a connect fix a drink
brandy yeah what do you want oh no just
like a little ryori binish nothing I
don't know what I have as far as I only
like some I could just I can I know what
I'll do I have motivate aquila right now
I have a lot of tequila too I'll be
right back no I'll hold up on this call
where did you see the sign I was in
Florida okay so wasn't in LA and ours in
Miami oh yeah Miami and miss my cell
phones welcome to Miami yeah and my
other my other idea that I want to do is
which trait we won't have I don't think
a lot of time for both but oh baby my
other my other thing that I really want
to do is um I was in Minot North Dakota
right after I think I told you about
this in Bend like right after the
election and then there's like a
billboard that was like free shipping to
canada if you don't like it like will
move you yeah oh and number and they'll
move you to Canada and I want two three
if well yeah I wonderly because I just
want to go to Canada like maybe I'm just
looking to move there anyway yeah I can
get the pre moving yeah if you just have
some stuff you need to store okay cold
storage save on refrigerated low what if
you wanted to ship drugs to Canada
see I heard that I do it yeah I'll be oh
yeah you could get set them up put a
bunch of like kiddie porn and a career
doesn't have them get arrested yeah i
see i do remember you talking about
that's interesting i wonder if they like
quickly we're like no we're not doing
that yeah even be enough k for amend
this amount of money even they've done i
think trump would win well I think know
this is right after he whoa they're like
you don't like it get out ya like like
you had to hear that like the whole time
like route through the early 2000s I had
to hear you don't like it get out and
then we got a break from people saying
that and oh yeah or do we learn here
eleanii mad because we were because we
were saying it yeah we're we know now
but like I don't think that we were yeah
cuz they wouldn't think I never heard
that oh no yeah I mean I didn't say it
cuz I always liked the president that
wins like like I don't know I never fair
other file a KERS when they were winning
I likes Golden State oh yeah I like the
Yankees I like whoever's winning so I've
always loved our president every year I
I was just saying that the other thing
was the companies the companies that
will move you to Canada oh yeah really
like if you don't like if you don't like
the US anymore they will just ship you
out I think that's awesome so enjoy I
want to try to like see it see if I
could move especially if you're like
from la they'll be like so we're like or
like at you like a bell later there's a
border town that you want like you're
moving to bellingham washington you're
like well it's not going to I'd rather
move from Vancouver to bellingham than
from LA to bellingham gonna give them to
get you most of the way there and then
backtrack just a little bit Bellingham
Washington very specific reference in
there it's like the money our country
really near as far as the growing
there's this guy Paul Stamets there
that's like then not just like Adele do
they naturally grow yeah yeah okay crazy
down in Florida to right and there's
like this guy that's like
a leading expert on mushrooms I've been
trying to get him on my pod oh wow he
makes he uses like mushrooms to make
like filtration systems for NASA okay he
doesn't always doing them yeah and so he
likes thinks I just want to talk about
tripping around which I started also do
but but put your ad in person sure and
you wanna talk about intelligent zoom
yes did you Jana know that Bellingham I
knew that like the Northwest is a
popular mushroom yeah but very damp yeah
it's a great place for it temperature
wise i don't know i would think warmer I
don't know anything about growing
mushrooms AB it's fine I know I like a
cold rain other finicky is [ __ ] yeah
people go well unique cow pasture yeah
yeah the number one on a couch at ease
their kind of kind of everywhere I don't
think it takes much but there's
different species and the Northwestern's
like every kind of speed it also might
just be the culture out there that
they're just I think they also bik just
protect their in nature a little bit
more yeah well there's more of it yeah a
little more of it and a vol that [ __ ]
over that's what I said he'll know what
ya doin do you want to call that number
we need a few walmart yeah we want to
make a hundred thousand what do you
trade 50 note if the trade is a weird
term to other than just work it just
ended that's how this is going to go
maybe well it's super late this is like
it was wanting one in a [ __ ] 100-member
kind of 86 yeah it's just hello now I
just hangs up after up rings right so
it's like a price nicer hi this is the
place here I'll google that number and
see what comes up we could call bars I
just had an idea when I was fixing this
drink there's some bananas there and i
was like huh there any banana based
drinks that aren't daiquiri related mmm
you call bars and say that we want some
banana drinks or anything they could
whip up i kind of want a banana drink
now that you say that doesn't sound bad
there's a rum banana mash in like a
cucumber drink there's no you wanna it's
not a alcoholic drink but they have
no they have like agua frescas like
whatever there's like a cucumber and
there might go which is the biscuits and
horchata is a fresca but they have a
banana one and it's amazing it's like oh
you could mix that with like some fun
yeah it's really good i mean they call
it like it translates to banana water
it's like you know a platano de agua oh
you know what so when we're and Bend
Randy so me but especially my girlfriend
likes absinthe oh yeah and but we don't
like know what we're doing or anything
and Randy knows like comic cocktails and
whatnot and so he was like here's how
you make proper absent and which is just
dripping cold water yeah yeah they loot
it and we didn't know that and then it
made it so then over the holidays I had
absinthe and is like I was doing like a
magic trick yeah I'm like hey I found
the facebook page for that phone number
it says we buy houses in South Florida
solutions for buyers earn while you
learn how to become a real estate
investor make ten thousand dollars per
month in the process oh it's oxygen 20
has a YouTube video should we click on
it sure fifteen dollars a week so that's
2,500 oh hi I'm Bob we're not as founder
and CEO I get asked all the time what
makes Renata so straight pants are
simple we don't just teach real estate
investing we create real estate it's a
scam you gotta let it play out well i
know i know i know that has a thing is
our listeners cares at all only for
making major [ __ ] so just as there was a
guy on over the last the lender covers
Bob instructors what I have been
involved in over six thousand view we've
seen it all it's going they have made
money through it all that's wrong penis
and then how to make money from video
yes about it I like that you gotta drop
like that you're like oh wait assignment
if you off no I feel well what's that
there's this guy at likely produce them
yeah
there's this guy on under ever cross
that holds these big like this big
conference room speeches and it's like a
mix between Tony Robbins and house
flipper so it's like he's like you can
do it you can turn your life around I'll
have to do is follow my rules and people
are all cheering for them oh but they
pay to go to his conference and people
in you know on your way out there like
are you gonna sign up for our heart
three-week-long class and they're just
like the guys out making money flipping
houses is also making money stealing
from everybody right that guy was here
he says good help my grandma I I once
had a my my grandma who at the time she
would have been like 91 or something
like that and I am very very like with
it and she got a call whenever I told
this story before she got she got a call
one of those calls that's like your
grandsons in prison and need bail or
something like that and and it's not
that she thought it was a fake call it's
that she just didn't give a [ __ ] she was
like well serve them right he has a
whole show about drugs that party yet
and then we found out was so so the
cousin of mine is like you know in his
early 20s or something like that and
like not the type to send out christmas
guy like out send out christmas cards
and his single early 20s guy and so
anyhow she that year she didn't get a
Christmas card from him because he
didn't send a Christmas card to anybody
right so then she called like his debt
or someone in the family and was like
yeah do you think that do you think that
is is mad at me because I didn't get a
Christmas card from them and and do you
think he's mad because I didn't bail him
out of jail oh no what are you talking
about Isaac yeah when he's in jail in
Mexico and I didn't they're like what
and then that's how we discovered that
this has happened but my grandma was
just like [ __ ] serve them right quick
oh okay yeah
naw hell now oh hell no my grandma
someone was she has a computer and is on
facebook and all this [ __ ] and people
and she's her brain isn't working as
good as a youth grow and people started
[ __ ] with her and and got her to send
the money and stuff and I feel bad about
that it's terrible and so then I did it
oh yeah oh [ __ ] give me six thousand
dollars no no it wasn't that much where
you feel bad i mean i think i do but at
the time it felt pretty good free six
thousand bucks yeah well now you gotta
live with that guilt i mean i feel like
she should apologize to you really yeah
get her on the phone no no cuz she was
you know Paul like my parents were
trying to like wipe everything off the
computer so cuz like somehow they got
into a computer and uh huh and she but
didn't she would forget and then she
would call my dad and be like yeah they
called again and like kind of forget
that my parents were like don't talk to
them anymore like every couple days
she'd be like yeah I was talking to them
again they're like no stop it [ __ ]
just these ruthless people man like how
can you what I'm saying is a friend of
again oh god you guys not doing it I
mean we talk about a lot of stuff number
one it's not all Jessie to get some on
hating you for your time well maybe is
the rest of your family would call her
and talk to her we know that I mean yeah
I have you in job that's like the maury
argument there a slick I'm you're doing
a job I would have allowed things I
thought like they I got tricked into
thinking chase bank was actually calling
yeah because like I don't know how they
got their hands on it but I uh I like
read some story online about how like
things you can do for budgeting or
whatever and you can usually like in
certain circumstances you can get your
credit card in ribs lowered like a
couple points or whatever and so I
called to apply for this thing and then
a week later they're like hey we're with
Chase Bank I was like because I had just
gone yeah I don't know [ __ ] they figure
that out tricky and the like they had
hacked them or something like that or
whatever happened
and I start then they start out I was
like oh wait a second what what is this
I stopped like just in time yeah but um
but I have you guys had Ryan singer on
no oh yeah he doesn't worry oh my oh I
know this story about the like jerking
off kind of blackmail and yeah I like
[ __ ] I don't like what was the it was
like some chick was just like hey you're
hot and then like but hasn't been like
having like virtual Anzacs yeah okay at
campsite or whatever was yeah what
slightly on like how did they get like
did he meet her on facebook I don't know
a thing about I just know that broad
overview I think he's pretty open about
I don't think we're yeah no no i I've
heard him talking about it before yeah
some podcast or something like that but
I I don't remember what it was but I
know it was a people came on me about
the dory yeah we're what every one thing
to go through to I'd like oh and much
like saying X like a blast out a picture
of my dick or something like that I
wouldn't really care but that but I have
someone like and you're like a little
bit like like my height yeah yeah yeah
and yeah you're just like in the camera
like aldus cut your [ __ ] brains turn
that go so if you're gonna jerk off on
camera I know that this can happen and
only show them you're really good angles
yeah I make sure you have a good place
for me to ham it up like just be like
super hot while you do it don't look
gross but day I mean it's funny the
stories funny though and we should have
him on tell it but I a really crazy
funny guy anyway Jesus I don't have
sounds like [ __ ] conspiracy stuff and
one yeah yeah yeahs into that yeah we
should have what he did he have a semi
impaired or Mille you girlfriend is a
shapeshifter yeah yeah like you thought
there's like a reptile yeah I think you
still think we got it maybe we'll have
him on for like a double podcast or some
of these uh and it's just like a really
funny dude yeah I met him right who like
you're getting a weird [ __ ] he used to
live in date and hang out at that
Wiley's club do you ever do Wiley's
they no no I don't think so maybe I have
no I don't think so it's uh yeah
whatever it's there yeah but uh no it
sounds good I mean it's not that holds
like that whole area I note you gonna go
into the marketing meeting is like
they're hiring you as your app yeah it's
a thing well they kind of like stopped
working me there too for good reason me
and John Evans like that were you're
like thrown mustard all over yeah yeah
that's good he took all the that's the
VHS tapes you took yeah we like because
I was out of there was a mustard into
them yeah well there's a yeah it was
more of the VHS tapes like it's like dig
it was a condo situation and it was just
you know like a typical be room Conda it
was in a high-rise but it was like all
senior citizens live there but you're up
on the ninth floor and you had a balcony
and you know they pay [ __ ] whatever i'm
not going to justify our poor behavior
we you know [ __ ] drank a bottle of
[ __ ] tiger meister during the show I
went back to the club and they had all
these VHS tapes and a VCR we're like oh
let's watch a you know a movie we put it
in and it did the VCR didn't work we're
like of course it doesn't [ __ ] work
so then I had a wiffle ball and I had a
wiffle ball bat with me except driving
and composed ride was in my car it was
in my car I mean I wasn't like flying
with a laughing I had my car there and
you will all right well bad like if I
have a wiffle all about my car like it's
because it ended up there and i forgot
that is there but you're like well i
know just what to do in this situation I
had a wiffle ball bat like it's just fun
to play that fall through it it's okay
let's go to the park and you're looking
so I'm not going to have to be back when
we so we started playing like John would
like throw the VHS tape and i'd hit it
with the wiffle ball bat it was like
bounced off the [ __ ] walls either way
we destroyed all these VHS tapes and
there's just all these like all this
ribbon of VHS tape so then we just like
started winging them like we're up on
the ninth floor inner is like a big
hark right there so we're just like
winging them I don't know what we're
doing I don't wanna get throw them and
they were all like getting caught in the
trees and like blowing in the wind we're
like this like Cirque du so cool and of
course the next day we wake up like I
can't let you look out and it's not as
cool [ __ ] all the trees have like VHS
tape blowing and the gray [ __ ] Dayton
Ohio morning we're like a block and
there's no way to get them out of the
trailer were just like well I mean I
don't know so we go to the club and the
guy robbed well either way I forget his
name but the guy who runs the club his
son they called him Opie he's at the
club when we show up and he's like hey
uh would you he's like what you guys get
into last night oh my god no we're just
hanging out he's like oh yeah well I
drove past and a bunch of uh looks like
there's a bunch of [ __ ] VHS back up
in the trees were like I don't know it
was one of those uh like geriatrics that
lives downstairs and he's like well I
bet if I go up to that condo I bet all
been hers not still there no I mean it
wasn't even about the expense but there
yeah but then we also like because it
was a fridge full of just like all this
old [ __ ] like they just never cleaned
anything else it is like yeah Mayo that
expired a year ago just like I know so
we put everything in a pot and like I
like jumped it off the balcony like i
did my rough that was driving i was on
your side we're out we didn't we didn't
cause any problems like we didn't like I
mean we didn't hit anybody with like
[ __ ] mayonnaise um we were out of
control i mean like we were just like
all right because we never really worked
together that much because we were like
kind of on this area was like headlining
yeah morning on come party oh yeah yeah
we used to [ __ ] yet so that was like I
think maybe the first weekend we worked
there was just like organic i can go
crazy and and we did and then uh yeah
Wiley's never had me back since then i
mean some of those condos they should be
ashamed of themselves and it's like it's
just like it goes from levels of
irritation like why wouldn't you have
shampoo and conditioner in in this play
that's like a mild one we're like you
know I need to get ready for a show yeah
I'm like you you you booked emails and
have them in here with like no really
this [ __ ] vent gusting mattress and
it's always just like a bed frame with
like you know a double bed but sometimes
it like smell like a dead body ya know
it's an elder they all have that musty
like they take you back to like oh I
remember visiting a friend of mine in
college you have like a weird beach
house or whatever yeah it's like
everything's damned and like a smelly
bitsy yeah it's just insulting you get
to why should I ask you about that like
there was that place in a Dallas and
yeah I don't know what I like and that
and that one that one's actually the 1i
is just at and it's a nice it's a nice
condo yeah and no like shampoo and
conditioners like god damn it even when
it's like a nice condo it's like yeah
well the Gunners like Denver Comedy
Works have you ever been in there ya
know it's it for I got a [ __ ] i like
how can they afford to have this place
it'll you know when you real rat about
it so like I don't know man that place
is better than any hotel my opinion
because I'm here why I go six months
it's like a high-rise it's still that
high-rise well yeah but this is like a
two or three bedrooms [ __ ] this is I
might have been launched we've always
had a reputation of em know you like the
kitchens like stocked with like fresh
gallon see I didn't have no elk and like
breakfast bars and all this [ __ ] right
what the [ __ ] why can't every where we
like this I mean that's fine yeah if
there was some quality control in the
condo situation which i get a young a
club it's like cheaper to spend a
thousand dollars a month on a apartment
and pay two hundred dollars or three
hundred dollars a night for a hotel but
I just yeah I just
made a rule at one point in my age and I
was like no condos that yeah I'm afraid
are you [ __ ] old and yeah I'm just
done i did it i paid my dues i stayed
and [ __ ] and and that's that yeah that
Dallas one like I hear it's a good club
and and you even said well Conda is not
that bad and I'm like full but you can't
like make a rule and then be like okay
I'm you just have to be like no just
tell them I want a hotel and and they
would do it for certain people and I get
it I'm like yeah I'm not gonna pack it
I'm not Bert Kreischer i'm not going to
pack the club every time I don't have
like a decent weekend maybe and yeah and
you'll save you know a thousand dollars
by not putting me in a hotel but I'm not
going to go stay in the condo I just can
yeah well it was interesting when I put
myself up to the tour which I'm which
I'm still on but I did most of it
already different to like if it was like
my own you know and I feel like all the
risk yeah yeah and then I was like you
know having to put myself up and all of
a sudden like well now crashing on a
couch isn't so bad like how can one way
or because it's a dim yet you'll make an
extra survivor that weekend right and
also yeah you don't well I mean you're
doing okay like you know that you're
selling tickets yeah and like nice
Airbnb and whatnot but yeah it's still
it's a little insulted but but that was
I remember you called me because it's
the Winnipeg one that and that place is
the [ __ ] that that's what I made the
rule I haven't told them because i like
that club I told them I was like dude
you just need some new pillows he's like
really going to complain about the
pillows I'm like you need to sleep in
that bed for one night just next time I
the free night go and sleep in that bed
and you'll get new like it should be it
should be like what was that rule
wherever we're like the slumlords had to
like stay in in the like efficiency
apartments or something like that one
week out of the year just to see how
this is some some place made a rule like
that that should be like comedy condos
if you are going to have a condo you
should have to stay in there for like
one or no you shut out of a there
thursday through cuz that the weekend
that i was there it's a long weekend
it's like a thursday
[ __ ] or it's like a Tuesday through
Sunday I to do it runs there that's
right those people and I can't imagine
like because not only is the Hondo the
most bare-bones piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
but there's nothing there there's a mall
there's a dying mall right across the
street that has like two stores in it
like there's a grocery store which is
that's great because then you can get
food but that place it's like it's like
psychological warfare to stay there
because it's like are you trying to make
me depressed like I don't have anybody
to hang out with I don't have anything
to do I can't go anywhere especially
before uber and [ __ ] like we need to do
you're just stuck here you have to stay
in the middle of nowhere someone took me
to downtown Winnipeg one time that's
right already works to club like three
times I was like oh there was actually
thing whenever you do another fan is
like cool neighborhood like this cool
down any I had ever been well that's all
I've seen that's what made me even more
angry because there was a there was a
kid like on the show and he like had a
podcast that he wanted me to do and I
was like yeah yeah come you know like
take me out like I was there was because
like I I'll look up record stores or
whatever like if if you can find like a
decent record store then there's going
to be it's going to be surrounded by a
probably a decent part of town and I saw
that like the you know that friday i was
there i was like oh this is a lot of
[ __ ] here this is a decent place but
it's 30 minutes away from where I'm
staying and I yeah I lost it at that
place I kicked a hole in the wall yeah I
think we're on vacation as we head up
your favorite yeah because I did the
club like two or three months after we
talked about talked about this already i
know i mean i'd be a little bit but it
let you know I just was like over a year
ago then I i just got an Airbnb and paid
for it might because they were like no
we can't give you any money for for
something and I said okay and I found
like a really nice Airbnb that was like
cheap because it's Winnipeg yeah I said
okay I'll just eat it and and it was
amazing but they were like well if you
don't mind me asking why why don't you
want to stay in the condo because you
have a notoriously like [ __ ]
Guantanamo
level living sequential break but I was
just like oh and i don't know i heard
that this is a queria and that basically
it was basically like four is like where
you go to da it was it was like old
people there it was all if you still
have enough money to not be in a nursing
home you know and and there's amazing
your collar alotta car yourself yeah
yeah yeah that's like that was the
beginning of the end was like I cut my
hand going into the place because it was
like it's like a weird door like that
you had to like turn the key and hold it
and then there was like a safety thing
and like there was a thing jutting out
and when I was like opening the door I
just like cut my like finger and was
just like this is now I'm like injured
to get into a place at all but that I'm
not proud of my behavior that but like
the night because then they like took
money out of my check that I wasn't
expecting for some Canadian taxes and I
was like yeah leaving it's a sitting so
I get all the money yeah but it was it
was just like one of those like because
it was like the amount of money i was
being paid was I was like okay if it was
like a dollar less than this I couldn't
you know I wouldn't do this and then
there were like oh there's three hundred
dollars that we have to keep for Canada
tax and I was like nobody told me about
this no way man I've just been like I've
been in Hell all week I've been looking
forward to leaving so I was an [ __ ]
they'll never have me back the week that
I was and I like that Club and I like
the dude to tylers is yeah I really
actually liked him a lot and i liked the
club and I like the audiences but like
[ __ ] come on yeah I got an argument
well because it's what about thank you
is that like all the shows are sold out
whether it's because of you or not there
also is so [ __ ] cold yeah there's not
like they just have a built-in like it's
a great place to have a comedy club so
the week we did I was there was when
Conor McGregor lost to Nate Diaz oh I
was in um I was at rooster t feathers
and that happen and I'd bet on a theory
I watched it on periscope because I got
up yeah I got out I was like I'm gonna
miss
I'm going to be on stage and when I got
out they are watching it on like an
illegal stream on the computer and the
fight before was when Miesha Tate beat
oh yeah Holly Hall yeah and that went
all five no it went long though maybe it
didn't either way I got off stage being
like yeah I probably already over hadn't
even started yet and I was like yeah oh
yeah and everybody there wanted her to
win seven was like mad at me when I was
like yeah but it's like four to one I
had a great I had a great weekend and
Winnipeg and I had like it was like a
nice brand new apartment with like a
cool kitchen and it was in like a cool
French neighborhood and you could walk
across the bridge to get downtown and I
had one saturday late night show I got
pow hell no and then everyone didn't
like me but I'm not only good I wish
that I wish that they would I should
start asking for buyouts that's what I
asked for her they didn't know ya know I
would get rid of like things i wish i
was just standard like they're always
like here are you getting a curse I
Molly has been listening to this or
enjoying probably I mean I don't know
we've already given them about an hour
or an hour and seven minutes now already
thinking about Isaac stock photography a
little inside baseball but alright let's
do pocket lets people in the hallway
you're putting up with here's a here's
the thing though for and this is for
anybody the club quarters hotel if you
ever stayed at club quarters for dexter
$25 you can have a suite at the writers
hotel at all well if you book it advance
or just stay so when you show up like
them because that out um why don't want
to say the name of the club because
there might be some crazy fans involved
but there are some clubs they use club
quarters as their hotel and club
quarters are notoriously small [ __ ]
rooms but i don't know how i found out
but maybe the front desk was like go for
$25 do you wanna upgrade to a suite for
twenty-five dollars and i was like what
yeah so for like a weekend for 75 bucks
you have yeah like a whole apartment
yeah so anybody who's ever staying at a
club quarters I people tell me like like
you
we be checking into a hotel you tip the
guy 20 bucks i'll give you a better room
and I'm like you could probably just pay
twenty dollars extra yeah i mean like
I've done that before where I'm like do
you have any I thought this is gonna
have like a nicer bathtub or something
and they go oh let me see oh yeah you
want a like 10 extra you know you like
you your bathtub guy oh man a pretty
crappy do you think I let me do they
know like because I don't you know I've
never like a nice big bathtub I will do
nothing but sit in the bathtub the whole
wonderful and especially high but if I
have a lady with me sure it bathtubs
just kind of like opposed in my house
have you fine with it but i do right and
the object of this house thinking about
a determine if it's a good pillows
though I mean getting everything about
hotels anything you dare turn them on
rinse them out a little bit see if I'm
the opposite it's my place it's [ __ ]
filthy because you're taking showers in
it every day and there's like [ __ ]
gross stuff it needs to be scraped out
even when you clean it good you know I
mean it doesn't look as clean as as
because then also the hotels when the
showers in the bathtub are separate
that's all you want to talk about when
it's like a jacuzzi tub that's one
because then most people don't even use
oh hell yeah yeah yeah oh I'm gonna quit
I got it going I trusted it because you
say hello to my bathtub hell yeah oh
yeah oh yeah I makes a little easier if
the why you can go yet yeah instead of
not yell you can't say no no I'm at now
we're pretty good at this hmm we're
gonna be really good I mean I like that
becoming a part of the potty I know we
did a Henry but like that's such a good
sound that's such a good clip I think
it's a separate pocket like oh five
minute podcast here I talk about like
things in the news you're like oh hell
no oh no no
exactly you think I care of my guest
today is this that's a good idea ting to
like a [ __ ] one minute podcast hey
this is uh Randy no you can't Christian
each week to be like okay we got we got
such a good guy oh that guy records out
yes yeah so quickly he forgets to Chris
cheese obey because no no I was another
king early same time in FL I thought he
meant that you like there's a Christian
like religious yeah I guess I kind of
you shun oh yeah the hell no podcast
well if you have time can I think we're
done with a skype in like we just do
that we have a guest on the phone too or
just like okay well welcome to the hell
naw podcast we get like everybody I mean
you got anybody you have to call us
we're gonna play a thing you're gonna
sing it we're gonna sing it and that's
it and its exact same yeah yeah I think
you guys would get like really good at
it under loyal to me I'll practice you I
own a rebuke so right of you review and
they say is it good oh he'll tell us to
the hell nope oh yeah oh hell yes to
hell naw hahahaha yeah I came along to
another episode of the hell no pasa our
guest is noam chomsky and we're gonna
play the clip and I'm gonna sing it than
gnomes gonna sing it yeah hey there mr.
chachi okay thank you everybody for
tuning is back next week with oh hell no
and then we go back to living in our
mansions of this
yeah hell yeah and then it's like 10
minutes of ads after after it's still an
hour-long podcast is all hat and no your
app stamps.com don't forget the shape of
the promo code aw hell no this is like
spelled super long he'll now yeah if we
hit 80 www or you know how your first
set off if you smell it correctly promo
code yeah what do you have where your
shows where this this will be out next
week a couple couple days well I'm a big
one is I'm doing largo again with it or
not 28 that I la luz de I'll befriend
the last one went really well largo
booked it again yeah welcome to that and
and then I'm uh yeah I'm adding co2
shane mauss ma USS calm i have around
that time I think I'm in like Oklahoma
City and Tulsa I have a northeast tour
that I'm putting together for end may
june i'm doing bridgetown comedy
festival delphi Sapa y'all be itself by
two well if you can we should grab lunch
or something Oh
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]